je regarde un rebond soir
[Applaudissements]
jean gabin mesdames messieurs le
croisement parfait entre fifty cent et
michel audiard alors on s'est connu à
longtemps avec ça
[Musique]
et je t'emmènerai
seront créés direz c'est la guerre je
les braves tous les lycéens mais thomert
réalité sur toi moi je l'appelle et on
se retrouve ce soir avec votre deuxième
livre à l'est publié aux éditions don
quichotte
alors on y viendra mais prenons les
choses au commencement votre vrai nom
c'est charles m booth charles parce que
votre père était un admirateur du
général de gaulle et d'ailleurs et vous
voyez comme officier j'ai raté mon coup
vous avez vu valley high j'ai pris un
vrai gaulliste quand même
votre pseudo donc ces gens là bas les
gens que vous aimez georgen way j'aimais
bien
ce le phrasé de l'aigu ça va avant
c'est-à-dire star à bout ce langage
d'après ce qu'ils avaient à malakoff
dans paname ou et cetera et cetera
maintenant que c'est perdu un peu mais
après c'est bon il faut que ça tourne un
peu mais c'est surtout j'ai poussé avec
tous les tous les films des années 40
mais le sol le mec qui s'appelle charles
est tout à fait c'est une des raisons
pourquoi j'ai tapé le blaze un
char l'ancien braqueur en vue de
remonter dans les coups bas voilà ce que
j'ai fait en entrant dans le légal
on savait
quand on
m
alors vous c'est pas t'as de beaux yeux
tu sais c'est un beau cul tu sais mais
mais l'esprit est le même en question
surnom il ya petit chat ça c'est bien il
ya le fossoyeur là sur meetic le
fossoyeur c'est un peu emmerdant quand
même comme run alors ça en mousse vous
êtes d'origine camerounaise
vous êtes né en 1967 père comptable mère
dactylo et vous allez avoir dix ans
quand votre mère quitte votre père qui
ne le supporte pas et qui repasse votre
mère avec son nouveau mec dans un
parking crois que mon père il attendait
mon géniteur attendait main madar sonné
et son conjoint dans le parking et il va
trouver la bonne idée d'aller à lui mais
le point le gus en premier comme ça et
vous éviter d'avoir les problèmes et
avec un flash avec un flingue et après
là il a collé six douilles ahmad harun
dont une derrière de lutte pour faire
comme si c'est un lapin mais voilà c'est
des trucs voilà
c'est pour ça que j'appelle le géniteur
est très étonnant c'est que votre père
donc il part en calèche mais uniquement
pour cinq ans ouais ils ont mis crime
passionnel même madame net en cloque
donc ça fait pour moi ça en fait 3 ouais
bah moi j'en ai fait 8 pour braquo d'une
a fait 5 pour les designers du hub c'est
dingue alors vous dites la mort de ma
mère est ma plus grande blessure ouais
je crois que c'est la chose que je ne
pleure pas que je n'arrive toujours pas
à comprendre et c'est c'est la raison ou
de temps en temps je saute un peu en
l'air quand les guides sont toujours en
train de chialer thain darron tard on
aime à darron c'est une colle monde
avance et si je disais que tu en as pas
du tout tu vas comprendre que le relais
ou partez à la dass c'est dexter un mode
de vie et à la ds vous dites là bas ton
meilleur ami
c'est à fourche à la fourchette parce
qu'il faut se défendre contre les mecs
qui veulent vous baisez g le problème
c'est que vous arrivez avec dégustions
ils ont déjà 18 ans donc temps en temps
avoir un petit derche pour des gus qui
ne voyaient gauzès bon bah on appelle ça
soit un viol soit une tournante parce
que vous voulez donc vaut mieux être
avoir une fourchette et vous faire
comprendre la personne que je te pique
revient l'oeil le dr tout ce qu'il faut
avec derrière mais je te le pitre est
quand même il vaut mieux avoir appris à
ramasser les cerveaux net avec les pieds
tout à fait mais je ne prends pas de
savon je préfère le shampoing
alors à 17 ans vous vous retrouvez dans
paris hélas pour becqueter si la
dépouille quoi ben faut survivre jadis
j'ai fait ce que je devais faire de la
rapine chauray souci bien l'étape quand
j'avais des rôles et voilà alors on fait
des séjours en calèche et ce qu'il faut
dire à tous les jeunes qui nous
regardent c'est si vous voulez faire des
braquages la meilleure formation ça
reste la prison au canada ce bateau ben
ça reste l'atout le voilà jeté avec un
bus appelé josé j'ai oublié son nom de
famille et il avait 38 berges et moi
j'en avais 18 et j'ai tout appris a
braqué en théorie grâce à josé merci
réussissent et la première chose que
j'ai fait quand je sortirai brad et
voila voila vous commencé à circuler
avec la bande des requins vicieux et
cela commence d'ailleurs le livre qui
vous amène ce soir que sa peine à l'est
ça raconte en fait trois mois en 1988 ou
vous donner avec les requins ambitieux
ensuite vous partez en allemagne de
l'est à istanbul à chicago toujours en
quête d'oseille coin en quête de zayed
aventure c'est surtout notre charte de
mon propre patelin vous essayer de
découvrir si la verdure à l'époque
justement plus verte ailleurs je me suis
aperçu qu'ils étaient un peu plus mûr de
temps en temps elle avait en allemagne
il y en a qui partent sous les cocotiers
nous partons en allemagne vous tombez
pour braquage vous fait sept ans de
taule en allemagne ouais au départ j'ai
pris 33 33 piges je n'avais pas capté et
c'est difficile de comprendre
l'allemande 1 heureusement quand on
appelle ça capital capital faire bref
c'est à dire l'argent mais voilà j'ai
fait en sorte de le sortir mais si je
fais le compte ça fait dix ans à la dass
et 7 ans en prison c'est vraiment parce
que beaucoup de rappeurs ont fait la
prison mais c'est bizarre s'est jamais à
cause de leur disque
alors dans votre livre raconte une
histoire absolument rocambolesque son
extraordinaire à un moment vous devez
livrer dix voitures de luxe à istanbul
voilà vous partez de berlin on traverse
l'autriche
la yougoslavie de tito la bulgarie la
bulle dirait la yougoslavie en ce temps
là la religion c'est la raquette voilà
je crois qu'il y avait fallu laisser
quelque chose et quand même j'avais de
caisse en arrivant à istanbul il y avait
huit caisses alors ensuite j'allais à
chicago là vous menez vraiment la vie
des gangs de chicago et c c'est quelque
chose d'inimaginable de raconter des
trucs de fou à un moment vous utilisez
des des gonzesses comme appât way pour
kidnapper les mecs si tu as trop d'ozone
était en train de lui qui est trop beau
ben non on n'est pas le crif me dira de
péter ouais
quand vos entrées en france finalement
vous voulez écrire des livres en fait
déjà à l'époque et ses deux gynéco qui
vous qui vous branche dans la musique on
fera aimer dans la zip j'ai un regard à
louis blanc dans un studio et quand
j'arrive au rembourrage voix catherine
orages et fred chichin et c'est pas ce
n'est pas mon idée première minute
première c'est sûrement pas écrire ou où
commençait à gazouiller au micro je
voulais les mettre dans un coffre est
demandé 500 bah
voilà et il m'a dissuadé pour 27 milles
avec un chèque et puis je me suis retenu
et puis j'ai commencé
je t'emmerde jetons
tu vécu tous les maux n'est qu'une
réponse
[Musique]
ces lacunes dans tous les cas on est
ravi que j'écrive y est pascal est super
bien écrit les histoires de riffs rock
un style la justice c'est ça qui est
bien
alors vous pratiquez le script work out
alors c'est des exercices en fait de
force avec des éléments du mobilier
urbain c'est du poids de corps c'est pas
de la musculation et c'est beaucoup plus
difficile de faire d'eux de construire
un accord avec
seulement avec son corps vous faites
partie d'une équipe qui s'appelle à
peniche d'un ultime
j'ai montré la photo à michel cymes tout
est là c'est que de la gonflette trace
au café vous
je suis au contraire admiratif écoute on
va voir ce que tu sais faire charles
vas-y
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'est pas de circulaire mais bon
voilà il ya pour les abdominaux voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il ya simon goubert ce sera un mondial
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on boira l'eau
il a quel âge je vais sur mes 49 bah
bravo
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu